what's this too shady
from santa that's crazy a ps5
i didn't even ask for this eminem
surprised fans when he popped up in this
skit
on saturday night live dear santa i
can't believe the year is almost over
it's getting colder i'm a year older but
i'm still your soldier
you're my hero cause you always bring me
the assist so once again we're back to
zero here we go my christmas list
pete davidson stepped into eminem's
shoes for a parody titled stew
where he writes letters to santa hoping
to get the elusive ps5
[Music]
the song of course a parody of m's 2000
hits stan about an obsessed fan
dear stan i meant to write you sooner
but i just been busy
you said your girlfriend's pregnant now
how far along is she
look i'm really flattered to record your
daughter that and here's an autograph
for your brother
i wrote it on the starter cap eminem
briefly appears at the end of the parody
on the tv in stu's basement
sorry stu
jason bateman took on the episode's
hosting duties
what do you guys want for christmas but
this is the only christmas gift i need
same for me yup oh okay so i guess you
don't care about world peace
and kate mckinnon held her own in the
cold open with her impression of rudy
giuliani
it's great to be in a courtroom where
i'm not the defendant poking fun at the
cringeworthy election fraud hearing
that took place last week in michigan
where viewers jokingly thought
it was an snl skip this election was
stolen from the american people
with a level of trickery not seen since
houdini
country singer morgan wallen was finally
able to make his snl debut
performing his song seven summers
alabama
to no consequences
[Music]
he also appeared in a sketch where he
made fun of himself for getting kicked
off the show
in october you're gonna do the right
thing and accept responsibility for what
you did tonight
well what about snl they're gonna have
you on two months later i promise
there aren't many people willing to fly
to new york right now wallen was
previously polled as the snl musical
guest after being spotted on camera
partying without a mask in alabama
just days before he was supposed to
perform on the show
which violated snl's covet 19 protocol
i think i just got to be aware that most
of my actions will you know
if especially if i'm in a public
situation it's going to be brought to
life
and before all that kind of happened i
didn't i didn't i don't think i really
truly understand the
the reach that i have and i haven't
handled it the best way
at all but if you don't want people to
to see those kind of things i guess do
it in private